[Inaudible].
How can you tell if someone is anatomy superfan through their knowledge of
different enemy series? Is it by their collection of figurines,
posters and flushes? Maybe it's by how they dress, or even if they cost a fight,
we brought together seven enemy superfans, but one is alive.
If the group discovers who the liar is, they'll win the cash prize.
If the life survives, they win the cash prize.
[Inaudible].
This is odd men out.
I'm sure like the first question that's going to get asked is what's your bigger
enemy, you know, obscure.
Or animate that really, really helps you.
Can't tell him your favorite underrated animate.
Cause you clearly haven't watched enough animate to be an enemy super fan.
You had to watch the show to know.
I think it's very hard to actually try and pretend you're an enemy fan.
I'm really excited to play his game and see how my detective skills are.
Ooh, obscure. Let's see how obscure can we get?
Goodness. COVID doesn't have a lot of dialogue, which makes it special.
I don't know. I love lots of animals.
Category circus.
There's too many people don't get this.
Oh, banana fish is not really that obscure.
All right. Kurt banana fish is solid. Hot take least favorite anime,
hot take least favorite database.
Do I have news for you buddy
off Amazon demon, Slayer hoodie feels a little bit generic.
Sailor moon bottle opener.
Dang. That's a popular animate though. Kurt.
I really don't think it's current discovered after this round
for the rediscover up to this round.
Where does everyone watch animate?
So where you might get some illegal sites, you might get like crunchy roll Hulu,
Netflix. So we're going to see.
Oh, where does a room anywhere? I.
Prefer Hulu, mostly.
Flicks these days up till a few weeks
ago. And no.
Either Netflix or illegal sites. Suzanne may kiss. M R I P.
Yeah.
I am with Chad.
[inaudible] yeah, let me get in there. I feel okay.
Okay. Who should I vote for?
Please tell me I'm most suspicious. I think I'm going to vote Antwan out.
I'll vote for Katie. I'm sorry for Jennifer.
Well, for Sunil, she was the last one to say rip kiss animate.
When something is big to the community as kiss anime dies,
like that's the way you react. I think I'm going to go with.
Katie. I'm going to vote for Katie. Sorry.
The person eliminated this round is
Katie.
You will have 10 minutes to prove that you're an enemy super fan by
taking a photo of your enemy related possessions or collectibles.
I already got it on my desktop.
You guys will have 10 minutes to do this and the time starts now.
Cause I was like, what?
We're let me grab this nice Coco figure. Cause.
This is Mario scrunchie. Oh, included all my is my favorite.
So I'm just going to cover this dude's face anyway,
because he's a trashed character.
Table's a mess. Why is there a random toothbrush?
Anime fans should understand this, that there's late nights of bingeing.
I have this it's my panel badge because I was on a panel for anime NYC.
I think my Comic-Con badge counts.
I'm a little worried because a lot of these things are like pretty mainstream,
but that's just because the mainstream anime or what.
I want to put this picture. It's an inside joke with my best friend, Bridgette.
No, one's going to understand it, but it has anime on it.
I have a normal closet in my room and then I have a second closet and this
closet is purely for cost.
Time to take my photo. Now I should have this the other way around.
See the covers. I
put out my truth. Oh, okay. Here's a nursery toast.
He's got a, uh, Joe just bizarre venture hat. Okay. And dragon ball hat.
Not from spirit away. I'm screwed.
I don't know. I'd be like, guys don't buy as much stuff unless it's on Farid.
Oh. Ooh. Cos play.
Sorry.
I'm not understanding the things in this picture made me poor for loving anime.
I think I'm gaining the trust of the people.
And physical Chan.
That is definitely animated. Flax.
Definitely anime. It's like, wow. I feel like septic.
Oh my God. We got here.
Classics.
I don't think it's Gabriel anymore. He has, I trust.
Did. Everyone's gotten a at them and then a body pillow.
Character. The rest I can respect though.
Bro.
I know this is anime, but I love the frog way. This is a NovoTAL wall.
This is not what it was like froggy wallet. This is animate. Oh Jennifer.
Oh Jennifer.
Ah. There's the full metal Alchemist. It's too soon.
He had a good shoe shopping King factor.
It's the float.
I love that shame Kings though, to me, Gabriel,
we're going to bite on the classics man. Me and Tony. We would vibe together.
I can vibe well with Antonie.
But why doesn't he have any like new stuff every day.
Things cool. And then they bring in one thing to bring it down. What is.
If y'all don't know that he's talking about? Um,
uh it's okay. You don't have to know.
She got some plus she's. Ooh. Okay. Okay. Ah, I trust them.
Some of this is animated though. These are just, um,
a man I'm suspicious of Jennifer. Now.
I feel like everyone's going to react and be like, it's not enough.
Did you play dang on Rabo or just wash the
anime for sure. Better than the show.
Oh my gosh. I have had the Pekichu clock for many years.
He's mine now. I'm still like Pete. Good. You thought.
Oh wow. She has hell of a Nana Fitch. Oh the phone.
I love the cheese.
Shooter. I'm crying.
Is that.
A wait? Is that a body pillow or a regular pillow?
Is that a body? Pillow? Filler. Regular pillow. Okay. I think Kurt is a Weaver.
Don't be surprised if your body pillow is missing tonight.
Okay. Now that's a threat.
Everything came out strong and that's why I'm concerned.
Tony's collection. I love it.
And what had to get stuff, but it was all like anime from like 10 years ago.
So that's why I'm like a little suspicious.
Right now. I have to go with cat.
They could just be a cosplay or not necessarily like a real anime fan.
His closet was very low key. It didn't have much. I'm so sorry.
And Toronto, I'm going to vote for you,
but it's I'm voting for you because I feel like you're voting for me actually.
A little suspicious of Jennifer faced on the picture though.
Her merge is very little.
It's more of James than MMA. I'm sorry, Jennifer.
I am most suspicious of Jennifer. I got to vote for Jennifer.
I've got to trust my heart.
I got to believe in the heart of the cards you get a reference.
The votes are and the person eliminated this round
is Jennifer
Sinead. Good luck everyone. I'll be playing fire one. Faith's revelation.
[Inaudible] Kurt. I knew it. I knew it. Sorry.
Each person will get 30 seconds to tell everyone the story about an
experience you had related to anime.
Susan, I went to eight Cod in Fort worth, Texas, if you guys haven't been there,
it's kind of like cowboy city.
And so none of my friends cos played at all and we went to go get dinner.
And because I was a poor student, we had to stay far away from the con centers.
So you went to get breakfast at this like old timey diner.
And I was the only one in cosplay and I was just surrounded by like grandmas and
grandpas who had like,
no idea why this weirdo girl was just like so out of place.
And I think that was like probably one of my most embarrassing stories.
That's kind of related to like a Cotter animate, whatever,
and just like live your life.
I was actually introduced to anime by my parents. Not,
they didn't know it was that though. Uh,
my dad showed me speed racer because he grew up watching that.
And then I didn't know it was anime. He didn't know it was anime. I watched it.
And then I was like, Oh, this is cool. They're talking a little funny,
but it's cool.
And over time I started to learn about it and I really enjoyed it. Uh,
got into proper with criminal alchemists. I feel like a lot of people, uh,
and in drag Waze and then, you know, show on track. Then I like, I,
I liked it so much for being a part of my career.
I make videos of all the time I talk about all the time. I,
I mess with you in my time.
I'm normally a very shy person and I don't really, I'm not that social at that,
but I have this friend who I cost play the, my hero, academia, moms with,
and we make like public target, Tik TOK videos.
And what you've seen on me probably have, because they always blow up.
For some reason.
She actually got me out of my shell and cause playing in public either way.
It got me out of my shell. And so now here I am talking to a lot of people.
Oh, I also got into anime. Oh, okay. Because of South park.
For me, it's uh,
any expo I went to about two years ago and one of my favorites is a champagne
shampoo. And I like Jean. Cause I think June is completely underrated.
Moving gets all the attention. And I went as him. Right.
So when I went to the convention,
everybody kept coming up to me and asking me like, Oh,
where are you at for a samurai? But like with the Yas gala,
I ended up getting there yesterday, but he's the black samurai. He was in Japan.
And most of the commission I had to like correcting people,
but I had the long hair. So I thought that would work in the hair,
tied back and everything.
So I thought it would have been fine gene for life though.
He's my he's my husband.
I totally relate to the getting up with cause plays at convention because like
cosplay shorter, he always gets mistaken for Moneta somehow. And I'm like.
People are really mean disrespecting Moneta. Oh yeah.
So like we're gonna fight right now.
So me and my friends were at a bowling alley and then two of my friends got to
the side of me and like I held out the ball like, um, uh,
raises Shuriken from Darren.
So when he started like throwing like the shocker in there and I started like
streaming, like super loud in the bowling alley.
And then I sent the ball and it would have been super cringy if it wasn't for
the fact that I got a strike strike on my life,
I will never try it again. If I do it, it'll just soil it's memory. I saved it.
The video will never leave my phone, posted it online. What kind of viral?
That's how.
That now I felt the best because I feel like we all vibed with each other. Okay.
It just resonated with the stories like with Anthony, like,
Oh I think he gets me safe.
I'm going to go for Curt. Just cause I need a vote for someone.
Tried to get someone out. I'd say Gabriel.
I think it's this time. I think it's again.
So few of us left. Anyone who gets like two votes. It's like, God,
I'm going to choose Gabriel. Just because he said shorter,
couldn't compare to a Minetta and don't kiss Moneta like that.
I'm coming for you buddy. You should already know I was coming for you.
And the person eliminated this round is Gabriel.
The Minetta comment.
I stand by what I said, Moneta is a King among Kings.
And there is nothing that can take that away from him.
Everyone feels confident that you already caught them all. You can end the gig.
Now give me a thumbs up. If you want to continue the game or a thumbs down,
if you think you caught the mole and wants to end the game.
I down for stop. Right? Okay. If it's one of y'all Hama,
be livid. I saw.
If it's green, you guys went like that.
Y'all if the box is red,
the mole is still in the game and you guys lost you guys ready
in three, two.
[Inaudible] the mall.
The real class trial.
We're going to have the mall reveal cam or herself.
Three, two, one top 10.
[Inaudible].
I am a geek, but I'm just not an animate geek. I like Harry Potter.
Star Wars is big for me. I also love game of Thrones.
I do like some anime and I'm very,
very much in love with avatar the last Airbender,
but that isn't actually considered anime.
I've only watched a samurai Champloo bebop. Uh,
most of me is AKI and that's pretty much it. Yeah.
Whose shirt is that dog? Oh, this bra, this cert belongs.
To my friend Devin. [inaudible].
That was the most malicious thing you could have done.
Can we all be friends?
Can we all like make a discord together or something and like lock down
and Antwan, you can come to, I guess.